Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier, and welcome to back to Inside.
Now! My voice is hopefully going to carry me through the rest of this game.
And, honestly, I don't want it to stop.
I know it's like generally like, what, two and a half hours to three hours?
I'm not one hundred percent sure, exactly.
but- and that's usually how I gauge these things. I just  judge how long they are to beat.
And I'm pretty sure I can get through the entirety of this in Comic Con's time.
I just don't want it to end; it's so cool!
I don't know how close we are to the end. We may not be close at all,
but hopefully some mysteries get solved here.
Ahhh, we're not going to make that!
Oh shit, broke my legs.
Broke everything.
Broke my will.
Broke my spirit.
So why couldn't I make that jump?
That seemed like something that would have been incredibly easy.
Only a fool would have stopped him from doing it!
And a fool is me.
So not really a mystery there...
Alright. [mark.exe startup] AABAGH! Okay, here we go.
Whuppity whoopty.
Okay. So, I gotta open that up. I'm pretty sure
this is just a simple procedure of opening this, all the way up,
and just jumping over.
Riiiight?
[mark.exe processing jumping noises]
There we go!
Oh c'mon! Oh man, I broke my back in such a bad way!
Oh man, how did- How did that not grab?
HOW CAN IT NOT GRAB?
HOW CAN IT! HOW CAN IT NOT?
Okay ... sorry to start this off with a little bit of stupidity.
But I didn't get nearly enough stupidity in the last episode.
I was too good with naming names, and therefore I wasn't reflecting up to my full potential-
of terribly stupid.
Maybe I just got to, like, sync it up with the swing
so that I only go when it's kind of swinging towards me and not away.
So if I go...
Now!
[mark.exe repeats noises]
♪ There we gooo! ♪
Oh yeah! Okay there we go.
Figured it was as much.
Oh! Well this looks like a place where people actually work.
Again, how?
How? How is it possible? I wanna know.
I mean, my goodness.
In a world with such strange things everywhere you look, you'd think there would be some logic​ in life...
But, alas, that's not how it goes.
Ah! Running out of air.
Okay..
mark.exe prepares leaving water noises
hib-a-doo-boo
Okay.
So we got a double whammy?
Okay, I probably did this in the wrong order. Shit
Come on, just do the...
I don't know what you're doing.
So.. Oooh [realizes what to do]
Aah...
Okay.
Bough-kay
[click!]
I know what this is.
markTemp.exe is experiencing trouble, cooling fan check commencing
Heh, heh, heh, heh, heh, heh, heh.
Heeeeeeeeeeeeeehhhh.
I know what you do!
I'm not too smart for ya but- uh, nevermind.
I'm not even going to talk about how smart I was when I started this off, with the terrible performance that I did..
But I am still wondering like...
why in the world is there such a labyrinthine base?
Why have we deviated from the dystopian era?
And-and-and, to be honest that dystopian era seem very recent-
Like that was a recent turn of events with everyone being herded in.
And where did they come from?
They were like recruiting... people.
Woah.
Hi... uh.
Don't mind me.
What is wrong with you?
Why do you have cables sticking out from you?
Are you a cyborg?
SAMANTHERA! ♫
SAAMANTHERAAAAAAA! ♫
What are you doing? I'm gonna run out of air..
Oh shit, I wasn't thinking about this.
For some reason.. [manly scream] Ho ho ho ho ho eeee
[Mark's hyena call]
Oh boy, oh boy, oh boy, oh boy!
oh boy, oh boy
oho boy, oh boy.
Well..
This ain't pleasant, where am I suppose to go now?
I'm assuming.
Stretch out as far as I can on this thing.
Go as far out, and then swim for my god damn life.
Here we go!
Oh boy, oh boy, oh boy...
Hey hey hey hey....
Wooo... Not today!
Not  ♫ toooooodaaaaaaaayyyyyy-  ♫
And I also want to know what she is, but there was a little clue that she had wires coming out of her.
So she could be a robot?
Which would be a logical explanation considering
I don't imagine that there is a lot of...
supernatural occurrences going on in this environment.
Oh boy, oh boy, oh boy. I went the wrong way. I did not know I needed to go
DOOOOOOOOOOOOWWWWWWWWWWNNNN
AHH Hah!
Oh man, I just wanted to cut away.
I didn't want the people at home to have witness what happened to me.
I didn't know that I was going to need to... Oh God damn it.
Hi... hi Samanthera~
Hiii...
You're looking lovely ;)
Yeah, is... is she even is she liked plug into something? That's so weird.
Okay.
Yes... so doing this.
So it's not too far,
to the next rope, but it is a good haul away from the next area.
Okay, so I need to get as much as possible.
I don't know if it's gonna matter; I am dragging a bit on the ground.
[makes swinging noises]
I don't know if we gonna get much higherr-
Okay, here we go! Here we go!
Wait maybe I can, wait maybe I can-
Oooh  Ahhh!
I don't need to, it's a fool's errand, ah haha
Good thing I discovered that right before I actually did it.
[random noises]
Alright, ♫ up we go, up we go ♫ Okay.
[hatch closes] Alright, so far so goo-
Aahh [more jump noises]
Now we're gonna get it because I got a much better head start.
Okay, alright, okay. Uh
Aah, woah, woah. Not good, not good..
Heh heh ha ha ha ha haaaa haaaaaaaa...
Samanthera~
Your time is up~
You shall not get me.
Okay, where am I going now?
Oh good golly, I don't know where I am going.
Ohh,  ♫ where did it come from? Where did it go? Get the fuck out of here, RUN, OHHH!
Okay, alright we're good.
Okay we're fine. Everything's hunky dory.
Okay, so I gotta use this for some reason.
And apparently the reason is not as obvious as-
Climb upon it and do the thing, okay so I'm going all the way up to the hook .
[swinging noises]
I'm not facing the right way?
It's harder to swing.
Eh.
Oh boy, uhh hit the button.
Hit the button! (x7)
[VERY MANLY SCREAM]
Aww, that's not the right button, oh boy...
I think all she does is just drown me.
Not that's any better than the alternative but-
I think that's just all she does.
Okay. So there's gotta be something to do with this.
Let me uh.. Let me at least face the right direction.
Unless..
OH! THERE'S A BUTTON UP THERE!
OH! How many people were yelling at me at home?!
I thought that was just a red liiight.
Ohh.
Well this is a thing.
Where am I going?
Why am I going here?
'Cause I can't exactly jump up to it from the-
Ohh, oh, oh oh, ooooh.
That is the thing!
Ha ha HA ha ha.. Okay.
So that's good. Now, she's farther away,
so that should mean I've got more time ...
before she gets me...
AAHHHHH! YEAH HEH HEH HEH, baby.
YEEEAAAAHHHHH HEH! Okay.
I gotta get up before I lose all my ox-oh-jan.
Okay, but I got it.
Where are wh- How is this sea level, is the question?
I mean obviously it's not sea level, but just a... [creaking noises]
Horribly,
disgusting water...
But..
[swinging noises]
[pooffl]
Okay. [another creaking noise]
[started noises]
[even more started noises]
[INTENSIFIES]
Okay, anyway.
[laughs] Has anyone actually gone to see the video yet or else am I still just-
Illogical nonsense?
Can you? Can you do a thing?
There we go, ohh I just got to push it.
I gotta to boosh it!
Oh there we go, now it's good for this... Not good.
Not good, not good, not good, not good.
Well, I would be scared if I didn't know you were already there.
Alright, you better be done.
You better be done or else I'm gonna be very upset with you...
You better be done trying to kill me.
You better be done with all your bullshit.
I'm not gonna be able to open it this way.
HO! It don't work!?
HOO! HOO-OH NO!
My survival is stuck!
I can't open!
This. Damn. Gate!
[Mark pretend sobs]
Okay anyway.. How about now?
Oh magically it works, who would have thunked? Okay.
So down here I gotta like probably make another break for it.
Well this doesn't look promising..
What does this do?
OH NO!
OH NO! I needed to press it again!
Oh God.
OHGOD!
AAAHHH!
I DIDIDIDIDIDIDIDI- Don't, don't, don't, don't.. Don't.. Okay.
So I need to press it twice, is the big picture thingy.
Alright, I got it. I know what you needed me to do.
I KNOW!
I know a thing or two about knowing things.
And I know many things.
Alright. Press it twice.
How would anyone have known that without like, going through that twice?
'Kay, boink.. NOpe that was [nonsense]
Hey! Hi Samanthera! How you doing?
Yeahhh, my face is cool to uh, grab and strangle..
Ehhh..
Okay, so you need to wait a little bit longer than that.
Timing is crucial..
And I'm not good at timing things...
[opens hatch]
Okay, so not instantaneous.
But just LONG ENOUGH!
OHHH SHIT!
I wasn't pointed in the right direction.
I- I- I don't think that would have worked anyway.
I don't think there would have been enough time.
So she's gotta be farther away, is the thing..
So there's gotta be a way to get her farther away.
Ohp-nope-no there's not!
Well, shit. Welp.
Ooooh!
I gotta hit the button and go back out of the water, I think.
Okay that makes more sense.
Because, that-
Timing it down there is gonna be [word vomit] damn near impossible.
So, I gotta.. I gotta hit the button, get out of the water
and then immediately...
I gotta fish 'er over to the other side and then come back.
So I gotta hit the button...
Hit it.
Get out of the water, outofthewater, outofthewater, out, out, out, out, out, out, yes!
Woah-hooah, man that was too close!
Too close!
TOO close. [strange old man grunt.]
Alright, then I gotta' splish-splash over here..
Oooh, I'm over here, now!
I'm over heeeere.
[nervous noise]
Ech. Ech. Ech.
Get out- Oouufvvv.. Ooohohufufu.. Okay.
So now I should just be able to press the button,
and carry on my way as fast as I need to.
That's the idea, anyway.
Man, I can't believe this kid is still brave enough
to just constantly be goin' for it--
GUN IT GUN IT GUN IT- Get- Don't get squooshed!
Okay.
So hopefully, that'll be the last that I see of that little girl.
Little robo-girl.
"Shuh-man-thurruh."
And then hopefully
I'll be able tooooo..
Make more progress in here.
They have done a lot of water levels.
This is me talking about game design again, but,
like, they have done quite a bit of water levels.
Which is, something's that's actually kind of--
[loud scary noises]
Ooo-kay!
[manly screaming] Ahhh! No! Samanthera!
Don't do it!
[thanks for waiting]
Noo, please! Samanthera!
Ooooh..Samanthera, whyyy?
Well this is scripted, so.
I'm assuming the reason will be expounded upon very soon.
Well. Am I dead?
Oh, whoop, there I go. That ain't good.
Oh that's not good.
Oh boy.
Oh no.
Well, this is dark..
Ooh..
Oh man...
There's such cool visuals, though.
Woah, what? What is that?
Where did that come from?
What is that?
Has she been trying to help me all along?!
Somehow? (Not 100% sure how..)
O-kay?
[confused laughing] What was that?
What was plugged into my chest!?
Oh man.
Still can't move.
The fish are very interested, though.
The fish are *incredibly* curious about my ~body~...
This is w- HELLO? HI. HOW ARE YOU.
WHAT ARE YOU.
Oh, you're a light? Okay, better be just a light.
Better not be anything else but a light...
Hi, who are you, what are you?
What is that over there?
What are you!? WHAT ARE YOU!?
Oh, what is that?
What is any of this?
Is that a-
Ehh, it's probably just a decomposing body part.
Oh man.
Woah! Hey! Ho! Blrblrblrblrgh!
Wait, nope.I guess I'm okay.
Apparently now...
For some reason, I have the ability
to breathe underwater perpetually?
Maybe I'm slowly being turned into one of them...
[Spookiplier] Slowly being transformed from the inside out...
Who knows what I'll be at the end of this road?
[really freaky]
Will I even be human?
Or will I  be different... Inside.
I dunno.
I dunno, I'm trying to be profound and it's not working.
But this is fascinating.
So, there's some sort of like bio-mechanical type
device that fundamentally changes people.
I- It's the yellow lights.
Yellow lights are kind of that idea.
Like the yellow lights on the helmet,
and the yellow lights on whatever the hell changed me,
in that way.
So there is something to this.
I just don't know what, yet.
I'm sure it'll be revealed at some point very soon
but for now, it's just an odd thing....
I was supposed to drown, and that little girl/robo,
did something to me.
Whether intentionally-
Woah! Hello, dead body.
Whether intentionally or not, did something to me.
That looks like a baby, or a fetus...
On the wall back there, it looked like a fetus there for a second there.
I wonder it that's a-
Whoa!
Whoa! Whoa! Whoa! Hi!
Whoa! Hi! Whoa!
Hi!
What are you?!
Are you alive?!
What. The. Hell?!
Okay! I-- Goodbye.
What the hell?
That is just weird.
That is so weird!
ugh
it's an understatement to say that this small journey of this child has changed him...
but it's just fascinating
by the way, (stuttering) I-I-I have noticed the numbers... I-I have been noticing the numbers i just didn't know if i needed to call them out for any particular reason.
but, like I remember seeing a lot of two's and now- seeing that three I'm wondering if I saw a lot of three's before.
Am I supposed to go to the light or am I supposed to explore a bit? Lemme go down just in case because
you never know what's down here...
Besides black inky DEATH.
But other than that, there might be something of note.
ooh, like what the hell is that th- Uh hello!
okay...alright then
alright- uhh
OKAY
Don't know what the hell this is doing. Wh- what am I doing?
Oh... (Realizes) OHHHH IT WAS BODY PARTS THAT'S WHAT I SAW!!!
oh no, oh no, oh ho no, oh god, oh ho ho god. Oh man
Hold on tight little Billy!!
Oh boy.. ah!
ohhh that got close! (Laughs)
oh man, okay- alright go for it or go up I don't know which is better.
At this juncture.
oh man go wherever the body parts came from- that is so weird.
ohhh maaan that's sooo weird!!
(disgusted) aww this is horrifying!
This poor kid
I mean maybe lucky kid cause now he can breath under water and that's cool i guess!
But this just seems where they dumped all the bodies...
ooh man...my guess- you know what I guess all this is? Alien invasion, that's probably what it is- the big thumpy thump that's an alien.
Alien machine tryin to keep us all suppressed.
That's what- oh shit.
Shouldn't done this
Shouldn't have done this.
Shouldn't have done this- I fucked up
Fucked up- Aaaaah!! My- My head!! (Laughs)
Dammit, goodbye- goodbye little Billy!
Goodbye
Alright
So, gotta wait till it goes after. Can't be too easy.
Gotta go away, then come back-so yeah this must be some-it's some external force that has gravely interrupted normal society in this world
ah shit
goddammit-goddammit I was cranking the wrong way on the yank!
I hate when I crank the wrong yank!!!
So, it's either aliens...or some horrible government experiment gone wrong...
okay
(talking nonsense) Wait did i go the wrong way? I went the goddamn wrong way again goddammit!!!!!
ugh such a fool.
Now go down-click the down button this time Markimoo! You're gonna remember 19 names or 18 considering you didn't name the dead body what's up with that you insensitive prick!!
I don't know, (sad voice) I don't know!
Okay I'll be fine
(makes grunting noises)
I don't know what this is for but I did it.
So, I guess I'm just hopping for one to the other
(sighs)- also I love the way the light works. The light is a very important theme in this game from that I've seen so far
I'm- I'm not sure how correct I am on that assumption, but like definitely the way light works and light being like a guiding light, light helping-
I'M GONNA DIVE IN!!!! WOOOOOOOOO- nailed it.
Nailed it. I don't need to breath (flaps lips)
Bunch a stupid
kay, where am I going?
Why am I here???
Was I not supposed to go down?!
Was I- ohhh I might've just wanted to jump in and then immediately pop out of it?
That probably was a good idea, that'd probably help me a lot.
Ahkay I'll do that!
Yeah that- that seems more like, yeah that's a good idea.
Okay so
Yeah but lighting has been a very thing, because most of them the light is very monotonous and most of this game is very cool tones,
very grey, very blue those types of- WHAT IS HAPPENING WAIT A MINUTE WOAHKAY
BACK THE FUCK UP TWO GODDAMN STEPS INTO REALITY ZONE AGAIN AND YOU EXPLAIN TO ME
WHY THERE IS FUCKING WATER AND FLOATING BODIES IN THE CEILING!!!!!
(Mark.exe has crashed, rebooting...)
uuuh
I wasn't ready for that.
I'm not ready for that, I- I- I don't know what's going on here
I don't understand it. I don't get it. I don't want to get it. I wanna go home. I'm okay-I'm done with this, it's no good
es no bueno, no bueno
okay, so I think there's some semblance of a button up there and then there was a hatch where I can go into the water
That is a floating body up there!
That's probably quite a few floating bodies
and some other things that I don't want to
understaaaand.
Is this a lot of wha- okay...
What does this do?
Yep that's what I wanted. Why did I wanna
do that to exclude me from the rest of the universe?
This just seems bad.
This just seems bad. Why is that light burning on right now?
Where am I goin- WHA- SHIT.
Where am I now?
What was all this? OH! Is this where all
the money is located? Can I have some?
[Markiplier nosies] Okay
Good Job kid. You're getting stronger everyday.
Who needs food? Who need oxygen?
Oh!
[inquisitive grunt]
Okay
Wait, so all I did was close the hatch, but did that do anything?
I don't think it did.
Because if that closed the hatch..
unless it opened another one then we've got a problem.
All I would have done, I closed that hatch
Oh! I didn't see this thing.
Was this always here?
WEEEEEEE!
[sad Markipler noises]
huh
Yeah that didn't really do anything.
Yeah all I did was close the hatch so benefit did that do?
We got another puzzle on our hands!
We got a puzzling puzzler!
I mean, I'm not one to, like
want to jump to aliens, ya know
I'm- I-I-I I don't want to make that conclusion here.
but I'm still very curious as to why
anyone, anyone would have the motivation
to enslave an entire population for forced labor.
I mean, it may be humans but you know
I'm, I'm just trying to find the motivation behind
anything or anyone trying to
to do that. Like what would the purpose of that would be
And it seems like this entire world has been built
around this idea, even though it's very desolate.
Like these are nondescript environments, like these are nondescript, ya know
Quote, unquote "machinery environments." Ya know what I mean? So it's not really
obvious what it is or what it is not.
Know what I mean?
And anyway, we got one of these. What do we do with this?
Do we use it? Do we take with us?
Nope, can't take it with us.
So where do we use it?
Is this going to launch me into the ceiling and kill me?
That would be amazing.
WEEEEE!
Okay WhYYyyYY?
Why?
Oh geez!
But whyYy? Can I break that thing?
And what's the purpose of this device? This device makes no sense.
I could crush myself.
Could do that. [light bulb!] Oh!
Ahhh!
I know what I need to do. I need to time it so I can get it off the rail.
Because I can have it. I just need to time it so it goes away.
HABOINK! [laughs] Holy shit dude!
Woah!! What the fuck man?!
You need to take some aroma therapy. Man!
You need to work out some aggression cuz holy shit!
Okay so that doesn't help..
So if that doesn't help then there's something else that this needs to be used for.
But where?
Oh I know what it is! It can launch itself. Duh it can launch itself.
So if I put it on this incline here...
it'll launch itself at an angle
and then be able to get up there.
Don't hit me! [2x] Whatever you do, don't hit me!
I was waiting for you. HABLUF!
Nice! Nice bruh! Nice! Good job man! Good Job! You're really killing it out there.
You're doing a great job. I'm really proud of ya.
Okay, so now I open this, this makes more sense. So I just gotta- woo
[unintelligible Markipler noises]
There we go, I've just got to get this and time it so it's up there and THAT'S why I go around.
I got it.
HAB- nokay, we got it. OKAY! We are succeeding in all of our endeavors.
Yeah, it's really interesting, because these puzzles are, like, fundumentally the same
but they *flow* together very well. Like, I do appreciate the *flow* of it.
It's interesting.
Well designed, one could say.
One might say! but I won't say that.
But I just hope I get some answers soon, because, I've been playing this for a while now
and I'm still I-I- I'm- I'm more confused then when I started this game. Like
I thought I'd slowly be getting some answers because it
started out relatively normal, what with all in the woods
with, seemingly normal people, not great normal people, but, ya know,
seemingly normal.
and then it just got REALLY weird over time
like with this whole ceiling situation with the water and the what have you
So I don't know what to think, and I'm gonna press that button up there and
an-an-and oh! by the way, remember how I mentioned that
I had to wipe off the spit off my monitor, the old spit that's collected over the years
I can already see,
specks forming from
the new generation of spit that's going to join the old! [laughing]
So yeah, it's, uh, it's not good.
Its not good bruh. So I just need to hit this- OH!
Did that light- was that light always on? That light was always on right?
HUP! WEEE! Okay we did it!
We did it!
What did we did?
We- whatever it is we did it!
Oh hello! What are you doing?
[sexy grunting]
Why is there a radio up here?
Why would there be a radio up here?
That doesn't make a whole lot of sense
Uh-oh! Thank you!
Good thing that was automated or else I wouldn't have known what I was gonna be doing.
So what did that do?
Do I have to follow the line?
Follow the yellow line, but  it kinda just ends there.
Huh..
What could that have done?
Oh I guess
[light bulb] OH! I- that was a bonus!
Oh! That's the bonus!
Oh, those are the bonuses, I thought that was something I needed to do.
It didn't seem obvious that that red button was hidden so..
I get- I know what I need to do, I need to get into that
watery area, for some reason to go upside down, I don't know why it is.
But you need to take this over there and launch it on top of the other launcher thing
so it launches you doubly onto the launching- launch
Did that make sense?
Did that make fence? okay...
So all gots tah do
is drag this back, over here, onto the thing,
double do the thing then we're golden.
Crank this up [2x]
Pull this over, get on top
Easy Peasy! and it's gonna go
yep! There we go HUBOICKY!
[disgusted] uh....
EEEE IT'S THE WORMS! THE WORMS ARE BACK!
Oh my god! The worms are back!
How does all this work? I do not know, but the worms are back. Ugh...
[disgusted] ugh... UGH!Uh, uh, uh,  that's not good.
UHHH! YOU HAVE NO HEAD! STOP THAT!
STOP THAT! This reminds me of SOMA now.
Like you know the ideas in SOMA where
ya know machinery taking over people, like
That- That's coming- coming back in big way.
right- right- right about now
and especially the prevalence of water.
Oh hello! I don't know what- oop! okay do I...
do- do I- do I need- oh boy!
oh boy..
Why did that fall down?
What was that?
What was that, ugh...
Maybe I go through there?
No...
Maybe I gotta pull the other thing out, there another thing on the other side. Yeah. There is okay.
I don't know what this is and I don't know who built it and I don't know- woooo..
That guy was having a bad time over there.
He got bumped.
His rest was disturbed.
Ahh so weird...
So weird [2x], okay.
So anyway, I'm all out of time for this episode.
I'm probably going to finish this up in the next episode.
I can't wait to see, what is going on here
or maybe not. Maybe there is more to it than I think there is.
but we're almost there, either way.
So thank you all so much for watching! And, as always, I will see *you* in the next video! BYE-BYE!
[Flibbity flam funky Outro Music]